alors là un sujet qui vous tient
particulièrement à coeur et mes liens on
en a parlé tout à l'heure ensemble et du
aura-t-il bientôt un personnage de
dessin animé homosexuels c'est la
question que se pose actuellement les
internautes
après la diffusion de la bande annonce
très attendue d'un film d'animation ses
28 minutes sur arte qui nous explique
tout cela la reine des neiges c'est
avant tout l'histoire de deux femmes
fortes et indépendantes dès le premier
volet beaucoup ont fait justement de ce
film une allégorie des bienfaits du
coming out
il faut dire que cette princesse tranche
un petit peu avec les codes du genre
parlant elle n'a pas besoin d'hommes
pour s'épanouir ce qui est assez rare
donc quand en 2016 disney a commencé à
écrire ce deuxième volet ce deuxième
film est bien beaucoup ont voulu les
encourager à aller encore plus loin de
leur volonté progressistes sur twitter
par exemple de hashtag ont été lancées
mais qu'elle a gay ou give elsa
girlfriend ainsi qu'une pétition pour
qu'enfin une princesse puisse aimer une
autre princesse
car imaginez quand même l'enjeu
symbolique d'un tel scénario
chez toutes les petites filles de la
planète qui s'interrogent sur leur
orientation sexuelle ça pourrait
évidemment faire changer les choses
alors le premier film avait engrangé
tous demain un milliard de dollars de
recettes
en france le dessin animé a fait près de
5 millions d'entrées est-ce que là on
est sûr est sûre chez disney sur une
question alors disney où les autres
implants pour sûr que ça aurait autre
sur une question de morale ou est-ce
qu'on est sur une question de souffle
parce que j'ai l'impression un peu que
les sous compte énormément dans cette
histoire et d'émilie tout est parti de
la chanson libérer des livres et que je
r personnellement
écoutez je déteste cette chanson que
vous écoutez les paroles c'est sur la
gentille petite fille que tu dois être
dissimule ne ressens rien ils ne doivent
pas savoir est en fait tout le monde a
vu ça comme une chanson sur le coming
out
parce qu'au bout d'un moment là dit moi
je suis libéré libre et donc je fais mon
cabinet intelligent core à tous que je
suis gay disney n'a jamais réagi à ça
parce que justement ils ont entretenu un
petit peu de mystère parce qu'ils savent
d'un côté qui vont se prendre toutes les
associations notamment aux états unis et
aussi en france et de l'autre c'est
quand même sympa pour eux deuxième c'est
un peu dans l'air du temps de voilà deux
peut-être avoir flirté en tout cas
donner le sentiment que moi ce qui me
disent oui voila moi je suis pas plus
militante que ça contrairement à ce
qu'on pourrait penser sur ce plateau
s'ils doivent le faire je trouve ça très
bien pour plein de gamine s'ils le font
pas c'est un petit peu dommage parce
qu'ils ont été précurseurs dans de
nombreux dessins animés
je les forcerait pas mais moi ça m'agace
un petit peu tu fasses le truc de voilà
on a peur de perdre et soudan du coup on
n'y va pas dire est entendue grise et de
non exactes eux mêmes
l'accord qui a roulé non mais pas du
tout disney complètement capable
d'assumer ses choix
vous croyez jour et que c'est bien
mouillé quand même un bruit et financier
peut-être qu'on ait ôté leaders
d'opinion ils ont mis ils ont mis des
gens avant avant d'autres grosses
sociétés jdir c'est à mon avis c'est une
interprétation des gens et moi ce qui me
donne ce qui me ce qui me rend dingue
c'est que tout ça parce que on est forte
et libre et indépendante et qu'on n'a
pas besoin d'un homme alors on serait
lesbienne non mais non c'est juste le
girl power c'est juste qu'on peut on n'a
pas besoin d'un homme pour exister
vous imaginez ça veut dire que là on a
le cas pour la reine des neiges donc ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire le livre de
la jungle mougli c'est quoi son délire
il est zoophiles guerra et de lamballe
où il tombe amoureux de lui et c'est pas
sa valeur préférée un film comme ça mais
oui oui c'était à tort mis d'accord très
bien oui j'ai beaucoup aimé la question
mougli c'est quoi fondez lire c'est bien
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais c'est
vrai que j'ai le sentiment que moi on
vit dans une époque en fait où il faut
injecter de l'homosexualité ici ou là en
fait sous prétexe il faut faire évoluer
la société ont il faudrait que tintin
épouse de capitaine haddock parce que il
faut faire évoluer la société
moi je suis pas d'accord avec tout ça
parce qu'en fait j'ai pas envie d'avoir
une politique des quotas
selon laquelle il faudrait 50 % de héros
homosexuels et 50% de héros hétérosexuel
et qu'elle suit des tribus kanakes telle
est l'idée qu'il faille
exactement c'est le vad d'imposer les
choses laissons les scénaristes grèce il
ya une héroïne homosexuels qui arrive
tant mieux ce sera dans la logique des
choses
néanmoins je n'ai pas envie qu'il y ait
derrière d'elodie qui force les
scénaristes à dire allez c'est dans
l'asse dans le livre de la période
il faudrait rénover sexuelle alors mes
séjours de la jungle et l'air du temps
mais le livre de la période ça veut rien
c'est juste représentatif de la société
alors oui effectivement aujourd'hui les
homosexuels garçon/fille les trans tout
on est un peu plus on essaye un petit
peu plus d'exister entend démonter donc
disney devrait un petit peu suivre le
truc parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'enfants
aussi wii ont besoin d'avoir ces
représentations là tout a failli se
soucient pas ce que tu as toujours su
que tu étais hétérosexuels mais les
gamines qui se pose est qui sont massés
bien aussi qu'ils aient pu se tourner
vers une transition qui disent que ce
sont des dessins animés qui sont
vraiment pour les plus petits et que
donc il faudrait attendre et faire des
dessins animés entre guillemets plus
spécifique pour les adolescents alors
moi j'ai 36 ans je continue à les
regarder aller voir au cinéma parce que
justement on est tous d
enfants et on devrait tous se faire un
petit disney un petit pixar de temps en
temps ce que ça fait du bien aussi donc
allez-y jimmy sur ce sujet si j'ai un
peu sceptique parce que est ce que c'est
vraiment le rôle des dessins animés de
d'éduquer en quelque sorte la populaire
alors qu'on a besoin de ça pour faire
évoluer les mentalités est ce que la
petite fille le petit garçon qui se
posent des questions trouvera des
réponses dans ce genre de dessin animé
est-ce que ça à faire que la société va
plus l'accepter et la rendre inclusive
comme on veut je suis pas sûr je suis
pas sûr que ce soit à disney pixar
autres de faire ça je pense que ça nous
au quotidien aux discriminations à
l'embauché peut-être dans les médias
mais pas forcément dans disney ce que
vous ne pensez pas que justement se joue
ce cessez objet de loisir permettrait de
banaliser et de dire cela est peut-être
ailleurs ce que mettre autant d'énergie
dedans et je ne dois pas faire mieux
ailleurs peut-être je sais pas je accord
je me pose des questions on vous a posé
la question également à nos
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent est
si la reine des neiges devenait le
premier personnage de disney ce que
c'est une bonne idée ou choquer
détachées partagez vous êtes c'est une
bonne idée pour 52% ce vous seriez
choqué le terme est fort hein vous
seriez choquer pour 48% d'entre vous